all right let's jump into a sort of very
strange interview that fox news host
greg gutfeld did on uh
on his show i i i don't know if this is
still a comedy show or not it has a
laugh track it sounds like it's a very
strange show
now i've exchanged some messages with
greg gutfeld in the past and sometimes
when we talk about things he does and
point out how ridiculous and humiliating
they are he'll tweet and say you know
this wasn't good or something like that
so i understand understand gutfeld may
see this and he may not like it uh what
was notable about this interview that he
had is that it was with the former
president donald trump often in
interviews with trump trump's the only
guy who's humiliated um but in this
interview it's both trump and gutfeld
this is
this is maybe
this would make maria bartoromo blush
it's so
fawning and brown-nosing of donald trump
the interview opens with gutfeld
basically saying he loves trump
and his pr even like his prior critiques
of things trump said were maybe like not
fair it's very strange check this out
right and then you started and now i
think i don't know if it's love but it's
getting close and we like it it's it's
no i wouldn't say it's love but i would
say it's admiration
and also admitting that i was wrong
because i was focusing on words and not
deeds and now we're at a time where okay
there are no more mean tweets and we
have a really nice president because
he's been banned from twitter and the
country is in the crapper so who would
you rather have well i don't know that
he's a nice president
i'm not sure what is
what is the laughing like
is this
is there a studio audience that's
reacting is it a laugh track is this a
comedy show is it a news show it's all
very weird it's not working as either
quite frankly
but i can tell you the country has never
been more unsafe we have people pouring
in through our southern border which
everyone should be talking about that's
not true getting about right now because
of the travesty of afghanistan and if
you look at the people coming in by like
you could gut instead of saying wright
could so easily disable that and defuse
it and say oh
how have the numbers changed of people
coming in and how have deportation
numbers changed and you know give us
that trump would say well i don't know
but it's just it's really bad just go
just look just look hundreds by the
thousands and these are not the people
necessarily that wanted the protection
right these are people so are they
terrorists how many terrorists are
coming in and they were aggressive very
aggressive at the plane and they pushed
gutfeld is saying right and yes to every
single thing trump says after talking
about how great trump is
gutfeld then asks trump
what would you say to my wife to
convince her to get vaccinated
apparently
gutfeld's wife isn't vaccinated
and trump goes well i recommend it but
if she doesn't want to she shouldn't
like he he's he still has to be careful
because if he really says like just get
vaccinated his audience will go nuts
because you had
and i my wife you met my wife i don't
know it was like six years ago uh in
mar-a-lago she's still not gotten
vaccinated and i keep talking to her to
get her to get vaccinated and she hasn't
what would you say to her well first of
all say why is she not doing it does she
have some kind of religious things no
skeptical she skeptical doesn't trust
i think there was a laugh that like
there was laughing when trump asked why
if someone's using a laugh track it's
being used at very strange times russian
yes
that's the end of that exactly you can't
argue with the russians no you're me
very smart yeah yeah very hard-headed
yes i think i know your wife a little
bit right yes but she's great
20 seconds ago trump seemed not to
remember meeting her but now trump is
talking about how well he knows
gutfeld's wife could
is this considered a news interview and
uh let her do what she wants to do i got
vaccinated and i feel very good i think
we saved millions and millions of people
worldwide you know in 1917 they say it's
1918. almost 100 million approximately
100 million people died yeah i think we
could have been into that situation
because it was very bad and now if you
vaccinated the other thing it shows that
if you do get sick you don't get sick
like they were before meaning you don't
die exactly trump's right about all this
by the way so uh i would recommend but i
also say that let her have her freedoms
you know the word freedom right yeah
exactly and with you she needs freedom
she needs a lot of freedom from me i
found
out gutfeld the the premise was how can
i convince my wife to get vaccinated but
as soon as trump says her freedom not to
get vaccinated is important gut felt
says yeah exactly there there's nothing
trump said during this interview where
gutfeld wasn't like well
hold on a second um here then the
questioning gets really tough gutfeld
asks trump how hard is it to be
president from one to ten
was it a difficult job
question i bet no one's ever asked you
this i think i might know the answer
well
a five-year-old would ask this donald it
is it hard to be the pres that this is
what a little kid would ask so it's it's
not nobody is no no reporter a
journalist would ask such a dumb
question how hard is it
being prep being president from a scale
to one to ten
well i had now
here the laughing makes sense right the
the question is so stupid that i
actually think there was not enough
laughing here
two forms of presidency number one i had
to run the country work on the world and
do things and the other thing i had to
survive yeah the survival was much
tougher
um listen he was busy not only being
president but trying to keep up with
golfing
watching tv and fending off sexual
assault lawsuits really tough stuff and
then here's just the last clip
in this one trump suggests that taliban
leaders when he speaks speaks to them on
the phone
that they grunt now what's funny is
supposedly
biden would be bad for dealing with the
taliban here trump talks about when he
would deal with the taliban but it's all
about calling them abdul and saying they
grunt oh this is christmas it's
christmas they're still celebrating yes
okay so i told you about abdul he's
tough and when i first spoke to him by
phone
i said
nice to speak to you by phone abdul and
he goes
you know they're ferocious people
you know like you go to broadway shows
they fight they like to fight they've
been fighting for about a thousand years
however
what a humiliating interview and then
now i'm gonna now drop in the cherry on
top this is like nothing i've ever seen
um gutfeldt says yes to everything he
opens the interview by saying how great
trump is
he asks questions like how hard was it
to be president from one to ten he says
right to everything trump says and then
this guy named uh titus or tyrus i type
tyrus i think it is who has a wrestling
belt he's i guess a panelist on this
program
he says you know what was great about
this interview greg gutfeld you didn't
kiss trump's ass
tyrus did you watch the interview it's
beyond parody
take a look
normally would never do this man but wow
man that was
that was a written one
no but it was
it was a conversation and you didn't
change
no
people when they interview presidents
change you didn't kiss his ass what
what did you see the interview yeah and
i applaud you and you got a great you
had a conversation you even told him i
didn't like because i used to hear him
going this guy this guy here
and that was that was a great
conversation it is it is truly beyond
parody and it is just stunning that this
uh i mean what
that interview would have made maria
bartoromo blush
that's how much of a of a sycophant
brown-nosing interview it was i
i hope gutfeld feels humiliated because
he should it was a humiliating interview
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
just for documentaries my girlfriend and
i have been using the curiosity stream
platform at home non-stop i can tell you
from personal experience much better
documentary selection than netflix hulu
or amazon on curiositystream i'm always
finding documentaries by the world's
best filmmakers stuff you can't find on
other streaming services last month they
added a ton of awesome new titles to the
library i just finished watching
becoming martian
about the future of the human species
and its possible path through mars but
there's documentaries on every topic
imaginable science nature history
politics if you love documentaries the
way i do you are not going to find a
better source of brand new award-winning
docs anywhere else curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 off that means you
can subscribe for just 15 bucks a year
very reasonable considering the endless
number of super quality documentary
content that you have access to
just go to
curiositystream.compacman the link is
right underneath this video